lorsque j'étais enfant je passais mes
vacances j'ai ma grand-mère des textes
et de la musique pour accompagner ces
marcheurs des élus mais surtout des
anonymes venus dénoncer un projet autour
de la loi qu'ils jugent inutiles
peut-être mettre l'argent ailleurs donc
là il ya le lien ferroviaire entre
orléans et châteauneuf
ça me plante ça me semble plus important
parce que sa défense craint plutôt que
la voiture
on a besoin de la nature moi j'ai besoin
de la nature pour m'exprimer et pour
vivre la nature ça réconfort la parcelle
de bois de latin j a déjà été défrichés
c'est là que sera construit le futur
pont entre mardié et darvoy un pont qui
favorisera la circulation automobile et
qui pourrait faire du mal à
l'environnement selon plusieurs
associations
ç'a un impact sur le sol karstique
également qu' un trou enfin la loire est
un gruyère en fait et donc du coup le
pont risque de s'effondrer à moins d'y
mettre beaucoup d'argent pour combler ce
risque cette trouée la coupe une zone
boisée qui gêne en tout cas la
biodiversité de se reproduire ces
animaux disparus sont représentés par
sept au thème fabriqués par le collectif
pour incarner la défense de la loire les
opposants au projet en appel à maurice
genevoix l'écrivain récemment tenté au
knees et avec lui au bord du fleuve à
saint denis de l'hôtel
ce qui donnait beaucoup c'était la
lumière les jeux de lumière des reflets
entre l'eau le ciel des mais aussi
voir les oiseaux qui volaient au dessus
de la loire au dessus de ce paysage et
qui sont ceux que nous voulons protéger
aujourd'hui aussi ce projet de déviation
et de ponts divise depuis plus de 20 ans
la bataille se poursuivra devant les
tribunaux
[Musique]